[Music]
hey guys so I'm Edwin and today I'll be
talking to you about scaling data
products under startup constraints but
you know we all have constraints so you
don't have to work at a start-up if you
have problem hiring EPROM getting
resources or servers you know this
hopefully could be applicable as well so
a little bit about me I've been a
startup person my entire career I have
founded two companies that went through
the whole startup cycle you know venture
funding to the first prototype to market
fit to eventual acquisition and through
those lessons I've learned kind of the
constraints that are available to
startups and what to do about them so
today I work at tiny data which is a
small data studio we help other
companies make data products and we also
make a couple of data products of our
own so the case study that I'll be
taking you guys through today is testing
machine learning in production and it's
a journey that we we took you know
fairly recently if you guys are familiar
with machine learning you know that kind
of the modern machine learning to chain
the tensorflow the PI torch of the world
they have a very research heavy slant
and I think that's really a function of
the academic bent of a lot of the
researchers at makers of these companies
more recently there have been more tools
for deploying machine learning in
production so every framework today has
a model server if you guys are familiar
with them they are a little bit like a
web server for but for machine learning
models so instead of deploying a web
page you deploy a train model now a lot
of the testing tools for machine
learning are really focused on the
training aspect so for example in
tensorflow there's a data validation
tool that you can use to find and fill
missing data kind of solving the data
downtime problem that a bar talked about
yesterday but for servers in production
there are far fewer tools some of
maybe wondering well do you really need
specific tools to test machine learning
servers in production what can you use
existing tools you know why can't you
use a standard monitoring tool like data
dog to see if your machine learning
service up and running and I think the
reason is that machine learning is
fundamentally different you know machine
learning is is different from
traditional software in a fundamental
way so traditional software here's a
webpage presenting a very popular PDF
download today the server stayed up most
of the data so it's you know I don't
know what they're using but if
everything is running correctly and I
request a web page I should be able to
download the report actually able to get
a 200 status code so it's very
deterministic if something is wrong I
could get a different error code if a
wrong report is downloaded you know that
means that's a bug in the system it's
you know something that we can fix and
and and we should so it's very clear if
you run a cluster of containers
there are even ways for you to you know
check for help and check for life 'no so
and you can restart them if something
goes wrong so for traditional servers
you know things are pretty good but
machine learning outcomes are slightly
different so let's just say that I'm
running a image recognition system and
I'm trying to figure out if a picture is
a dog or a muffin
if the server has never seen one of
these pictures before you can never
really know for sure for sure you know
it looks like a dog probably is a dog
I'll give it a good 90 percent
probability but we don't really know for
sure for sure and that's really the kind
of premise of modern machine learning
and it gets trickier when we have new
versions so in machine learning you
often want to retrain your models and
deploy a new version or you actually
want to be fancier and do online
training which means that as new data
comes in your parameters change and your
your server actually return results so
two versions
the same two versions might return
slightly different results for this
picture now recently a lot of the larger
infrastructure companies are working to
provide kind of end-to-end machine
learning platforms so this is a new
product launched by Google recently they
call it's called AI platform and it
takes you through all the different
parts of a machine learning lifecycle
and it kind of stops that you can see
that a lot of work happens before
deployment
you know you train you develop you
organize the data you analyze but the
picture kind of stops at the deployment
level but this is not what we're doing
today for other types of servers right
we have a lot of testing and production
we even have chaos engineering where we
try to engineer disturbances to see how
systems react but today that's not
available for machine learning so we
went about a project of building a
production machine learning testing tool
and we had three requirements for that
one is that we wanted to be able to
generate new inputs against machine load
against model servers so given a model
we want to be able to generate new
unseen inputs into the systems at the
production level - we want to record
outputs from the models and three we
want to be able to have a feedback loop
where the outputs can be fed back into
the training system today I'll mostly be
talking about number one which is kind
of the steps we took to engineer new
outputs against model servers and you
know doing that's actually particularly
hard as a start-up we need two things
that we we didn't have access to
we need model servers that are not toy
based we need real robust model servers
so that we can do testing in it and then
we need access to you know real
generated real data just so that we can
see what the outcomes are in terms of
you're using a model server you know if
you you know open it tends to flow and
do a hello world
you know there's there's a few toy
models you can work with but they're
klymenos right there
not really robust enough for doing
testing so the the way that we went
around this constraint instead of you
know spending time building and training
our own model is actually the skip a
step we realized that there were a ton
of non toy model servers out there in
the form of commercial and care services
so these vendors all provide different
types of cloud AI services from text
analysis to translation to image
recognition and the image recognition
services are interesting in that you
know they're the easiest thing ways for
us to look to see whether something is
working or not you know their visual so
I'm going to talk about them the systems
from the vendors themselves they're for
the most part opaque you know they work
pretty well but we don't really know why
they work we don't know what the
training data set that they use are and
we also you know don't know really you
know what's the real success rate
internally they all have common features
you know there's seen the detection
facial recognition text detection and
the and also facial analysis now one of
the features of facial analysis is
gender detection so given the picture
the service will find the face given the
face the service will figure out what
you can about that particular face
including gender there is a research
project called gender shades that has
highlighted the the challenges these
systems have had classifying genders for
people of color very specifically for
women of color there's a way higher
chance of getting misgendered than for a
white woman so if you are a person a
woman of color and you use a system from
IBM or from AWS there's a higher chance
that you are classified as
man so we're interested in actually
taking a degenerate study a little
further and look at gender bias from a
different point of view you know can we
find other systems are the cases where
the train systems fail
so the your hypothesis here is pretty
straightforward
that gender labels that these systems
provide a train on traditional images so
if we present non traditional images
they're gonna not gonna work well so you
know they are again this is our internal
model that they the training data is
most least trained on very specific with
traditional data and we are interested
in testing the systems with non
traditional data so for example the
hypothesis that most labeled males that
the systems have probably have short
hair so here we have a picture of Alex
and zoo Looney who is the 6-3 240-pound
NFL linebacker and we're interested in
what the systems think it you know
here's so here we are using Amazon's
recognition system and you know the
facial analysis says that there's a 79%
chance that he should be classified as
female let's try the opposite ratio
meadow who was born biologically female
and identifies herself as a woman and I
AWS says there's you know she's more
likely to be a man so but I ate up yours
is not alone here we are you looking at
Watson the service from IBM and IBM
thinks that she's a man at a higher
percentage it said you know is that
something about her face that makes the
system you'll miss classify her so let's
take a look at a different picture
here's a picture of
the same person from years ago but you
know in this case she has long blonde
hair and this is IBM Watson whose class
which is classifying Rachel meadow as a
female with a higher percent certainty
so that's a very very strong certainty
here so you know one question that this
brings up is are these systems actually
doing facial analysis the faces to me
you know look very similar and yet the
classification are entirely different
you know why is that I actually you know
the again hypothesis here is that it's
the presentation of the hair and it's
the glasses so you know these are kind
of a one-off examples that I'm giving
but we really want to test the systems
in bulk you know we don't want to give
them couple images that we find on the
internet we want to give them thousands
or tens 2,000 images and get the results
back so as a start-up how do we generate
the data I think the good news for us is
that again you know there's constraints
we don't have a large internally label
data set but the internet exists so
whether it's you know Creative Commons
images from Flickr or a very well
labeled list of people from Wikipedia
there are tons of sources that we could
use and this is a playbook that I've
used before one of my startups in the
past cast TV focus on video data so we
prototype the initial product using an
open-source TV episode guide called
peptides and you know it got us going
with the first product and eventually
that product is now the global standard
for you know TV so if you use Comcast
that data you know is from the same
company that you know I founded but the
original source was an open source
database
so with this playbook we went about
generating data so on Wikipedia I have a
list of people from that I can get a
list of women from that I can get
specific women you know here we have a a
singer with short hair and there are
multiple images of her on Wikipedia and
we can kind of skill out with the
analysis rather than doing one off we
can now do them in bulk and again you
know the systems are too predictable
again you know with a short hair
she's classify as male so you know there
are a few more examples I'm gonna show
here's a man with long hair more likely
to be female
here's another man with long hair more
likely to be female and you know we're
gonna try other things right here's a
man with makeup so the hair
presentations is now you're not issue
here so I think this is clarify
classifying this person as a woman with
pretty high certainty and here's the man
with makeup you know not a feminine
make-up in any way but makeup and again
fairly certain to be a female so and
last you know another person we make up
so it's very clear that the if you were
to you know again those systems are
black boxes we don't really know how
they work but if you were to hypothesize
how they actually work you would imagine
data sets where faces with makeups are
labeled women you know faces with long
hair outside the boundary areas all
those label women and faces with short
hair a label man and we were able to
kind of have confirm that by automating
our data generation and testing here is
a screenshot of our tool you can see
that
the different services are listed on the
top AWS and so forth
and we have images on the left and the
return results from the various services
and if the results are in red then the
images are misclassified so testing all
these services in book required us to
write a common API so you know
internally we just have a common API
that can go out and test any to any of
the services and we can write special
plug-ins for for the intermediate layer
just so that we can add new services
very easily you know nothing really
changes on our on our internal end so
here's I think in this case this is a
screen shot of us testing women with
short hair wearing glasses and you know
that it's really tough for the
commercial services you know so why is
this helpful well beyond kind of being
able to pinpoint the issues that we find
that we also storing the results over
time and this means that if you're
running a machine learning service now
you have a scalable predictable and very
automated way of testing your model
servers progress over time and again you
know these are images that haven't been
seen in training and the reason why
that's important is that the you know
the systems will do fairly well for
image of senior training but that's not
how real life machine learning works you
know
Amazon recognition is not going to have
seen every picture that a user submits
so the takeaways for us from the machine
learning side is that even the best
trained commercial systems again this is
a system built by some of the best
people in the industry are far from
perfect and you know it's is
very very hard problem right trying to
recognize everyone in the world that
that's a hard thing to do and I think
that's maybe the reason why Google is
actually not in the mix you know if you
use Google's commercial image
recognition system you cannot get a
gender label out of that but the other
systems provided and you know they are
the event the vendors are more or less
responsive to research from folks like
kind data and other people IBM for
example is actually taking the
initiative to open-source some of this
training data just so that we can take a
look at the data and figure out why the
systems are working the way they are
some vendors are less open to that and
obviously with some of the images that
we've seen here you know they are larger
ethical and society though issues as
machine learning becomes more and more
prevalent I think the press or in the
media has a way of making this
probabilistic model that is almost by
definition imperfect into this something
different right into AI this thing that
returns the right results every time so
you know clearly if systems are
returning different results over time as
new versions get deployed deployers of
machine learning systems are going to
need to really manage and control it a
little more and you know that's going to
be intractable and cumbersome to the
test without tools and automation
already already the data governance on
the training side is complicated you add
kind of real life data from from the
wild into the mix and again you need
tools and automation so as a start-up
you know kind of our takeaways always
have been that you know we need to we
should skip the steps that we don't need
to build that have been built before
so now in this case you know we've
bootstrap servers with commercial api's
and you know we would strap the data
that we've used to test the systems from
the open web from public data sources
and you know we did that for the image
recognition domain for other domains the
different that are popular in machine
learning whether it is credit scoring or
other types of predictions there's an
increasingly large body of work around
synthetic data generation and there's
actually a talk yesterday you guys were
here from Andrew from tonic where the
talk where he talked about how to
generate data so if you're a startup and
you need data you know it's out there in
the web or you can make it and finally
you know automation is really startups
the best friend yeah we were able to you
know I guess you know these doesn't
really care whether you are one person
or hundred people you can you know
launched a thousand service the with the
same ease but it's a startup you just
have to remember to shut them down
otherwise this you know it's expensive
so anyway this is kind of a quick talk
sharing our journey trying to test
machine learning as a you know very
small team you can reach me on Twitter
at Edwin or send me an email or we have
lots of time for some questions I think
um so what would you do for problems
that are not classification problems so
like for example or recommendations
where there's no right recommendation
instead of you know yes or no yeah
so I think I think it gets definitely
gets trickier with you know a
recommendation where you don't know
whether is actually right I think that
the first part you know you can still do
the data generation part you can still
have a visual way of seeing what the
outcomes are and may and then you can
still feed the data back but it's not so
black and white
but you can actually we found in one use
case where the visualization letting
people see oh here they recommend in the
products were helpful because the the
data editors could visually say oh
that's right
that seems really off so the first part
yeah so it's still helpful but not in
the same way any other questions I had
one question sure one of your takeaway
points was that automation is a startups
best friend but at the same time
automation has a lot of costs associated
with it when do you recommend people
look to automating startups like
automating things versus doing things
you know I think it's the trade office
is your time is a big trade-off here
right it might take if it takes you a
couple hours to automate something that
only requires 10 minutes of work a week
it's not worth it
so in our cases we definitely look at
automation when it's a clear time saver
but there's things that you know as you
know as users you just can't fire off
you know a thousand image requests to
Google an hour it's as hard you just
can't use it you like to do that so in
in cases where the alternative is not
doing it that is very clear you know if
you can't do it with that automation
then automation has to be the only
option
[Music]